un tribunal bielorruso ha condenado a 11
años de cárcel a la líder opositora
maria kolésnikova una de las principales
voces del país en favor de la democracia
las autoridades la acusaban de haber
creado y liderado una organización
extremista para tomar el poder por la
fuerza kolésnikova premio sájarov a la
libertad de conciencia se convirtió en
una de las principales figuras de la
oposición bielorrusa en 2020 fue
detenida hace justo un año en septiembre
después de un intento fallido de
expulsión del país desde entonces se
encuentra encarcelada el abogado
opositor máximo snacks contra el que
pesaban similares cargos también ha sido
condenado a 10 años de cárcel a ambos se
les atribuyen también delitos contra la
seguridad del estado los dos niegan
haber actuado mal y kolésnikova ha
calificado las acusaciones de absurdas
con 5 kva dirigió la campaña de víctor
baricco el aspirante presidencial que
lleva encarcelado desde antes de las
elecciones del año pasado por el régimen
de alexandr lukashenko